and welcome to a blue trollops question
I'm Harris busquets here with Jon Moxley
the one-eyed Jon Moxley first of all
John how are you and how's the eye
feeling it's gonna heal up man
swollen gross [ __ ] you know you don't
want to see it trust me I'll take your
word for it so last time we saw you you
defeated Pok to become the number one
contender for Chris Jericho's aw World
Championship how did finally getting
that first title opportunity feel pretty
pretty sweet Phil and I don't know if it
was just the sea air or to finally get
that win over Paco after we had a time
limit draw on our first one so that
would have been kind of eating at me
when they get that get that win back so
to speak so it was a good uh it was a
good feeling just to uh it's good
feeling to set your sights on a target
and to nail it
to uh throw the dart the dartboard hit a
bull's-eye on the first try
yeah it's a pretty satisfying experience
absolutely so in recent weeks you've
made it a point of emphasis that you
aren't just a hardcore wrestler I know a
couple weeks ago you had a run-in with
Tony Khan when he made your match with
Kenny non-sanctioned how is that
motivated you sense to try and reach
that that very top of the company yeah
it's been fun
it's terrible answer yeah but there's so
many different styles and different
opponents and AW and that's like one of
the exciting things as a as a wrestler
and as a as a performer you mean walked
in a locker room you see this
smorgasbord of all this different talent
to work with you got an old-school
wrestler like Cody undefeated MMA star
JK really got a unique Darby al and you
got a high flier and samovar and all
these different guys always different
masses you're gonna have it's kind of
awesome just to be like I can just walk
out to the ring with nothing really on
my mind or any set plans of what I'm
gonna do and just kind of see what
unfolds and kind of almost kind of like
I can you know as a for the veterans on
the roster I can still learn and grow
and adapt and bring new tools and
develop new tools to the toolbox and
just kind of learn new things so you
know there's so much young talent
especially that has so much just great
new crazy creative ideas that it's great
to see them getting a shot like I was
like jungle boy and Markel stuck and
Darby and Sam Lara and George and Alex
see these guys we're so young and so
talented getting a shot on national
stage and just being able to be
completely be themselves unencumbered by
anything they don't have to walk around
on eggshells they don't have to try to
tow any company line you know telling
anything down they just get to truly be
themselves that's really fun for me to
watch I almost miss and feel like I'm so
fly guys the way you watch like your
little brother or something I don't know
I don't have any younger siblings but
it's something like that it's almost
like watching like a dog get older and
throw up and you know like watching a
puppy grow or something like that
getting off jag a little bit but uh yeah
it's just fun to be a part of because
there's just some
different stuff to do here and you know
I want to explore as many different
styles and stuff as possible you spend
that was gonna be a bad answer that was
a pretty good one he's first a non
wrestler like me who cannot even imagine
you know throwing themselves into barbed
wire or being dragged through glass how
would you describe what motivates you I
guess the number one thing it's kind of
hard to put into words but it's like
that uh it's the kind of the addictive
feeling that keeps you coming back you
know I don't do this necessarily I'm
fortunate enough that I get to do this
for a living so they bless the metal
don't necessarily do this for money I
don't necessarily do this for uh you
know it's nice to have you know fans
around the world that cheer you on and
can propel you and help you agree on
everything but I don't do this
necessarily to be famous that's not it's
not even a part of it that I always
enjoy I what really keeps you coming
back is that addictive feeling of like
being in the ring when you're like
sweaty Bloods running down your face and
you just you're in it and the crowd is
in it and everything stayed on all
cylinders and and you're just in the
moment and you know especially with like
the aw fans have been so great and
they've been the thing that's really
pushing this whole thing along because
when we show up you know there's these
hungry fans and all these new markets
were going to that just are the great
I've been the greatest fans in the world
like they have such a passion for
wrestling and they're so excited to be
here and to watch those different styles
and there's some guys and they you know
in three three matches in a row the
other day on the boat three days in a
row and it was like everyday I couldn't
wait til the show the next day as soon
as I got out of the ring I was like I
can't wait to get back in the ring
because I just I just loved wrestling I
the process of the process I'm like I
kind of thinking about a little bit what
I'm going to do tonight and just like
start warming up and like walk out into
the arena a little bit peek through the
curtain and see the buzz and the crowd
starting to fill in and there and just
the hold and then you know you're about
to go out and there from the bell rings
and the you know the whole process of
now being fortunate enough to do what I
love to do for a living and that's the
addictive part that keeps me coming back
looking back on it what's been your
favorite moment at aw so far you know
there have been several you know I was
thrilled too thrilled to be able to
shock people and girls people out and
really make people uncomfortable on such
a big stage in the match of Kenya Omega
match that people haven't seen a match
like that on national TV in decades if
ever you know and I love messes like
that look you know I like when I like
when it's uncomfortable in the room like
not a lot of people go for that reaction
but I really like that like not just the
a but the you know that was really
awesome I'll tell you a great moment
that was the stuff the last day on the
boat on the Jericho cruise at the end of
the last show Cory was just cutting a
speech giving out stuff to the fans a
few the boys came out I came out and
smashed a white coffee on my head for
reasons I don't even fully understand
myself but it was just some of the
wrestlers and the fans all just out
there on this friggin boat in the
million just like hugging and
high-fiving and it really felt like
we're all part of something like all
part of a team like this really is like
a wrestling revolution whether it's
way I don't know if you'd call it a boom
period necessarily from a financial
rating standpoint okay the business has
changed twenty years ago but it really
does feel like it's like a Renaissance
like it's cool to be a wrestling fan
again and now people are so connected on
social media and so forth that like they
can find other fans and meet other fans
and you know we're not trying to draw
dry people away we're trying to give
them what is what we're giving you take
it or leave it we're trying to all be
part of this together it really feels
like us and the fans like we're all on
the same team together and and it's a
stupid thing wrestling that brought us
all together
absolutely so we're a month away from
your World Championship match against
Chris Jericho at revolution on via alive
and there's been a lot of malice between
you and the inner circle of recently you
know obviously your your new eyepatch
and the injury they caused you how are
you preparing for that match knowing
fully that they're going to be a lot of
distractions leading up to it
luckily I've been doing this for a long
time I've been in the game a long time
of know Chris Jericho a long time I know
his I know his game on those strategies
I you know it ain't the first time that
I've been jumped and beaten down by a
group of guys it won't be the last
so I know how these things can play out
and for me it's just about staying
focused and calm in the eye of the storm
when I was younger in my 20s if somebody
tried to somebody stab my eye out I'd be
coming back trying to stab there I very
next day yeah I might uh somebody tried
to interfere in my match maybe I'll take
my eye off the ball and get distracted
and start swinging chairs and get myself
to squall apply it or something like
that and I think that's what Chris
Jericho is counting on is to uh you know
inflamed my aggressive side to the point
where I beat myself
so me I look at this man and I've
legitimately you know you can't ever
really pick a greatest of all time in
wrestling it's just too long of a
discussion there's too many people on
the list but for me for my money Chris
Jericho he's really making a case for
being the greatest of all time he's done
it in the 90s and 2000's in the last two
decades he's doing it again he's doing
something completely new and breaking
new barriers still here in 2020 with atw
so let's call Chris Jericho the greatest
of all time and it's not every day you
wake up and have to be the greatest of
all time that's a tall task but I look
at this guy I just know in my heart this
guy's noggin finding he's not gonna
submit me I'm gonna knock me out I'm
gonna beat him so it's just about
executing and keep an eye on the ball
and getting the job done absolutely John
I appreciate you taking the time and
hopefully we are again for me some time
soon exam bro thank you revolution live
Saturday February 29th at 50
dream on VR live